[Musique]
près d'orléans en sept ans leni 6 ans et
la petite dernière m'a dit trois ans
s'apprête à vivre une aventure
extraordinaire
comme beaucoup d'enfants de leur âge ils
adorent les histoires de chevaliers de
châteaufort ou cheval et enfin si la vie
dans un château
imagi is his quj y il sait tous que
c'est sa maison un château flight des
pièces d'or le roi à chaque fois et
décide tout ça me plaît
3 demain leurs parents marlène est
nickel les emmène pour un fabuleux
voyage à travers le temps
regard sur le bonhomme way for tu m'as
dit toute la famille va partir explorer
les châteaux de la loire et pas
n'importe comment pas vélo
[Musique]
et ça ne va pas être évident car ce sont
les débuts de l'apprentissage du vélo
pour les petits points devant
donc là c'est là la grande aventure à 5
on emmène aussi les parents donc c'est
trois générations et je pense que ça va
être assez sympa de partager ça vraiment
en famille grands parents parents
enfants et leur transmettre l'histoire
de la france et leur montrer que tout ce
qu'on a autour de nous c'est super beau
et que c'est vraiment bien je pense
qu'ils s'en rappelleront un sacré bout
de temps pour bien préparer les enfants
à ce qu'ils vont découvrir demain alors
l'icwa victoire et le château faraghi
même histoire du soir sont dans le thème
et c'est ainsi que le seigneur de victor
devint le roi du pays et voilà
et voilà ce que la famille va découvrir
demain les châteaux de la loire à
commencer par chambord l'édifice le plus
célèbre
visiter des sites culturels pendant les
vacances c'est une des activités
préférées pour 51% des français une
aventure que vont vivre marlène nickel
et leurs enfants j'aimerais bien que mes
enfants voient l'histoire autrement que
j'ai pu la voir et en étant petit à vélo
ils vont passer des vacances
inoubliables
un million de touristes se balade
aujourd'hui sur 900 km de pistes
cyclables balisées le long de la loire
un véritable phénomène
regardez le château lafite chômage mais
ces châteaux coûte cher à entretenir et
c'est une bataille quotidienne pour
subvenir à leurs coûts faramineux alors
les propriétaires rivalisent
d'imagination pour créer des événements
qui attirent les touristes
comme des spectacles de chevalier à
chambord sous la direction de christelle
ils chevauchent des pur-sang et font
voler les rapaces de françois 1er
cheverny est l'un des rares châteaux
encore habité dans la vallée de la loire
depuis six siècles rien n'a été vendu il
n'a pas changé de famille
voilà ma robe de mariée et on s'est dit
qu'il fallait la montre aux visiteurs
comme leurs ancêtres le marquis et la
marquise de vibrer règne sur les lieux
et met en scène la poésie et les fastes
de leur vie aristocratique pour attirer
les visiteurs ils ont dessiné des
jardins incroyable et font rêver les
touristes avec l'ambiance des bals
vénitien les gens sont très très bons le
château magnifique ça fait revivre les
deux vibrer nous ouvrirons aussi les
portes de leur vie quotidienne nous
découvrirons les exigences qui pèsent
sur les héritiers un bas niveau
dans une chaîne il s'agit de base être
le maillon faible de cette chaîne
conserver cet héritage est un défi la
pression est forte et les moyens pour
décompresser et tout non
[Musique]
visitez les majestueux château de la
loire vue de terre ou vue du ciel est
une aventure extraordinaire
de l'aîné au petit matin c'est le jour
du grand départ le t-shirt
[Musique]
marlène est assistante de direction en
logistique et des de la petite maddie
elle après l'organisation en main
on va resserrer ses branches qu'il prend
les casques et on va tous rassemblés ici
darrigade à l'extérieur mikael le père
s'occupe de l'essentiel
génial
alors on été chercher des vélos de
location pour pour le séjour est donc là
je les sors du camion pour voir les les
préparer correctement et que tout le
monde soit en sécurité sur sur les vélos
pour l'itinéraire la location des vélos
va leur coûter 360 euros + 18 euros par
bagage puisque marlène a choisi un
service indispensable pour ce type de
vacances l'acheminement des valises
d'hôtel en hôtel une personne qui venait
chercher les valises pour ramener à
l'hôtel comme ça en vélo en est
tranquille on n'a pas de bagages est
arrivé à l'hôtel soutenir les valises
dans la chambre on sert le guidon a
été bien droit avait aussi que l'on les
grands parents marie laure et benoît
viennent d'arriver c'est la première
fois que toute la famille va partir au
grand complet ensemble ils vont
parcourir 50 kilomètres à vélo
près
de dix ans
en plein coeur du val de loire le
château de cheverny il est un des rares
encore habité par ses propriétaires il
se transmet de génération en génération
au sein de la même famille depuis six
siècles voici la marquise constance de
vibrer ces journées commencent toujours
tôt chaque matin elle a le même rituel
étonnant
[Musique]
à ses côtés son fils maximilien 16 ans
oui c'est c'est quelque chose
d'indicible mais de mes d'extraordinaire
et
d'apaisant et puis on peut ressembler on
peut tous sortir sur une batterie ont
peut-être pas aussi fort qu'on veut
on peut se déchaîner et à la fois dense
et donc ça qui est magique quoi
constance de vibrer consacre sa vie à ce
château sa famille j mais il est
également ouvert au public alors là on
traverse un petit salon voilà on est
toujours dans notre partie privée et
puis on va partir dans la partie visiter
avant l'arrivée des touristes constance
de vibrer s'assure toujours que tout est
en ordre dans sa demeure
alors là le château est pas encore
ouvert au public donc on l'a encore pour
nous tout seul c'est le moment d'aller
voir si tout va bien et si tout tout est
bien calé en or
je fais un tour très régulièrement oui
c'est le seul
seul moyen de d'être au plus près de
tous en fait il faut que je fasse tous
les services quasiment tous les jours
alors encore nord aux
constances de vibrer vie qui fait depuis
24 ans originaire de bourgogne elle est
étudiante lorsqu'elle rencontre son mari
dont la famille est propriétaire de ce
château elle tombe amoureuse devient
marquise et ensemble ils auront trois
enfants
[Musique]
moi je me suis marié à 21 ans après un
coup de foudre petit à petit j'ai appris
a pris cette vie et puis puis ça s'est
fait
délicatement doucement et naturellement
la famille de vibrer a compris que la
vie de châtelain faisait rêver alors
pour attirer les visiteurs dans toutes
les pièces constance raconte tous les
moments forts de leur existence
voilà ma robe de mariée et on s'est dit
qu'il fallait la montre aux visiteurs
pour les faire rêver et ce à tous les
étages on arrive dans la partie la plus
haute du château et c'est une chapelle
dans laquelle notre fils a été baptisé
alors sur l'hôtel vous voyez mon bouquet
de mariée qui a aujourd'hui en quatre
ans
tout conserver ne rien vendre en prendre
soin de chaque souvenir armure boiseries
tentures constance et son mari oeuvrent
chaque jour pour conserver l'âme de
cheverny et cette mémoire ravi les
touristes
alors ça y est on a les premiers
visiteurs qui sont qui sont arrivés
c'est sûr qu'aujourd'hui sont les
visiteurs ce serait impossible d en
aurait vendu le château depuis longtemps
le château attire chaque année 350 mille
touristes la visite est payante entre 9
et 21 euros selon les activités
constance de vibrer et consciente que
cette somme est un effort
alors chaque jour de son bureau elle
vient le château comme une entreprise
familiale
ici on est dans des bureaux mais on est
également de notre partie privée vous
avez à la fois tout ce qui concerne le
bureau alors vous voyez ça c'est les
articles de presse
les vénitiens des histoires de salon des
cv des plannings voilà et puis aussi la
convocation du bac de mon fils donc
voilà tout ce mélange un peu mais
mais bon c c c la vie de château et
surtout d'un château toujours habité
voici son mari le comte charles antoine
de vibrer c'est lui qui a hérité de ce
château
je vis cheverny je vis pour cheverny et
il n'y a pas doute que c'est bien
entendu un héritage dont il faut être
digne dont il faut être fier laisse un
héritage exigeant
pour faire vivre le château et attirer
toujours davantage de visiteurs
charles-antoine de vibrer a eu l'idée de
remettre au goût du jour les fastes du
passé et notamment la chasse à courre
mais aujourd'hui n'est pas un jour comme
les autres c'est jour de baptême pour
les nouveaux chiots
ces jolis mots que j'ai pas pensé c'est
bon
là on baptise des chiots qui ont un
petit peu plus d'un an on gérera du
dictionnaire ou des noms qui peuvent
nous passer par la tête voilà la
condition que le nom soit valorisant et
en tout cas pas ridicule nicotine ces
bonbons napoléon on n'a pas de la marne
oui c'est bon c'est bon nacelle newton
nelson noblesse nescafé née du phare et
novembre pour le moment
cette année tous les noms choisis pour
les chiens doivent commencer par la
lettre n
le marquis possède 130 chiens une race
que l'on appelle les français tricolore
qu'il faut nourrir chaque jour
le repas de cette meute obéissante est
une attraction pour le public
[Musique]
les 65 kg de nourriture sont avalés en
quelques secondes
[Musique]
même si cela fait longtemps qu'il n'ya
pas une chasse à courre à cheverny la
meute reste le témoin de cette tradition
les pendant ce temps la famille de
marlène et mickaël fait ses premiers
kilomètres sur une route départementale
on change quand même avance était
absente en jeu c'est la première fois
qu'en sept ans et sur une grande route
mais si j'arrive à pédaler
geffray d'un peu doucement jusqu'au feu
tu freines super bravo
cinq kilomètres plus tard la famille
quitte enfin la grande route pour les
bords de loire les deux plus jeunes sont
derrière les parents dans un porte-bébé
ou dans une carriole ce magnifique le
parcours qu'ils empruntent s'appelle la
loire à vélo ce sont 900 km de pistes
cyclables qui s'étale de cuffies à côté
de nevers à saint brévin les pins sur la
côte atlantique
un itinéraire balisé qui permet aux
cyclistes de se rendre de château en
château il existe même un train qui
longe la piste dans lequel les
vacanciers peuvent remonter avec leurs
vélos sur le parcours près de 400
hébergement en camping hôtels gîtes avec
des services adaptés
entretien réparation et même garage
fermé de quoi passer des vacances
l'esprit complètement libéré comme la
famille de marlon et michael
si le nous y était il nous mangeons
j'arrive je vais manger mady
et relais comme c'est beau la
du coup redescendre pour info
cette eau fraîche est tentante mais pas
question de se baigner les eaux bleues
de ta verts sont aussi belle que
dangereuse
c'est la rencontre entre la brusque et
souterraines et la partie de la loi les
couvre chloé les points même température
il ya les ja les remontées du calcaire
qui seront du coup c'est pour ça qu'on
voit les tourbillons dans l'eau ce qu'on
appelait les sables mouvants
mais il y en a il y en a un peu partout
le long d'un petit ça fait plus d'une
heure que la famille est partie est du
côté des enfants ça fatigue à 7 ans il
seul pour la première fois donc
là on va mettre la sangle attraction
pour tu peine -1 d'accord ok c'est parti
et là tu reste bien écartées de maman tu
l'approchent pas trop tu reste bien les
cas tu m'as dit pas trop pas de sas
voilà ce papa à côté d'accord
allergique aux
[Musique]
anges de plus vraiment sa maman
le soulageant le tract ans
ils ont encore 12 kilomètres à parcourir
après six heures de vélo la famille
arrive enfin à sa première étape
cheverny
m'a dit vas-y pour ce bar oui c'est bon
on arrive on la regarde mahdia et le
château de cheverny
tu as regardé le château
[Musique]
super le château de cheverny qui
appartient aux deux vibrer et celui qui
a inspiré hergé le père de tintin pour
dessiner le château de moulinsart la
demeure du capitaine haddock hergé a
repris la façade de cheverny en effaçant
les ailes de chaque côté mais pour
l'instant cette histoire les enfants
s'en fichent eux ce qu'ils veulent c'est
s'amuser
[Musique]
qui tombe à tout va peut-être oui on va
les voir oui oui oui il va t-on dans
fois avancé dans les jardins on va
avancer dans les jambes
avant les bateaux michael approche les
vélos et quand on voyage à 7 c'est un
sacré boulot
alors
[Musique]
il ya toujours un antivol par vélo et
puis après il ya les antivols accessoire
qui permet d'attacher tous les
accessoires une passe en bêta et clis
sacoche et c'est pour continuer la
visite et puis allez voir les châteaux
tranquillement ça va ça fait pas mal
d'antivol mais sinon savoir
ont fait l'expo en premier non allez on
fait l'exposition soeur toujours dans
l'idée d' amortir les frais du château
la famille de vibrer à imaginer un musée
autour de tintin l'exposition est dans
une annexe du château
l'obscurité y est presque totale pour
mieux immerger les visiteurs dans
l'univers du héros vous fait ce jour
tout y est
le laboratoire du professeur tournesol
et les accessoires du trésor de rackham
le rouge ont même été reconstituée
balade en douce
pendant que la famille s'amuse avec les
aventures du capitaine haddock à
l'intérieur du château une fête
incroyable se prépare pour faire vivre
leur demeure et attirer toujours plus de
monde le marquis et la marquise de
vibrer doivent créer des événements
aujourd'hui ils ont invité une troupe de
passionnés pour animer cheverny des
amateurs déballent de venise il
collectionne plumes robes et masse qui
fume c'est faramineux
toutes femmes rêvent d'avoir un jour ce
genre de robot de costumes ce qui est
intéressant c'est que on incarne une
autre personne on devient princesse pour
le temps d'un week-end tu seras à
déguiser en fente huawei
et plein de plus enclins à paillettes
ouais ça va très bien ils sont
perfectionnistes et connaissent la règle
d'or des vénitiens leur peau doite
entièrement être dissimulé même le
contour des yeux ne doit pas apparaître
derrière le masque samba des combats
avant de mettre le masque ça c'est pour
avoir des belles fesses bien dodues
la touvre ça je fais part de mon
[Musique]
profond
peuple éprouvé
pendant que les marquis d'un jour
terminent leurs préparatifs le véritable
marquis des lieux vérifie que la troupe
est à la hauteur de ses attentes c'est
lui qui a invité ces passionnés pour
animer son château aujourd'hui merci à
toi vraiment vous donc vous embellissez
le domaine j'espère que les visiteurs ou
renverront le regard que vous méritez
chers amis soyez remerciés
toute la journée c'est 100 bénévoles
vont défiler et enchanté le public
le château de cheverny tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui datent du xviie siècle il
incarne le grand siècle une époque riche
et festive cette cérémonie est une façon
de le faire revivre en chair et en os
c'est la cinquième année que ce défilé a
lieu les costumes sont à chaque fois de
plus en plus raffinés
mais blake il faut se tenir correctement
la marquise bay surtout personnellement
car son public doit en prendre plein les
yeux dans l'allée centrale on va on va
faire une haie d'honneur pour les
nouveaux visiteurs
sur le perron en fait comme ça on va
faire une belle photo qui voile c'est ma
fleur préférée elle rassemble les
troupes et jouent le jeu des bal
vénitien
bonjour monsieur
je dis monsieur mais je ne sais pas
peut-être cette suite dames derrière eux
mais avec vous constance m la mise en
scène des réceptions des grands soirs où
chacun cache son identité derrière un
masque elle sait que le public rêve par
procuration devant ses costumes
fabriqués par ses bénévoles et qui leur
ont demandé des centaines d'heures de
travail
c'est très gracieuse gracieuse ça fait
rêver carrément c'est un autre monde là
on est en train de se dire où en est on
avec nous en plus c'est vraiment
magnifique léger rebond sont très très
bons le château magnifique ça fait rêver
après avoir salué tous les vénitiens la
marquise rejoint aussitôt son mari dans
leur bureau un pic à temps bon
je vais devoir j'ai envoyé l'envoi
[Musique]
ou alors ils fois non là il faut un art
mon avis un
panneau d'information les journées sont
rythmées par le souci de l'accueil du
public tout ce qui bouge il travaille
sans cesse à l'améliorer et rien n'est
simple bien sûr
que tu vas l'envié tout de suite pour le
faire faire la
porte en moi j'aimerais bien voir pour
faire vivre cheverny il dirige une
entreprise de plus de 60 salariés leurs
responsabilités sont lourdes et
l'imagination de constance toujours en
ébullition pour restituer la mémoire du
château pour enrichir les visites des
touristes
elle cherche sans cesse des anecdotes de
l'enfance de son mari des souvenirs
d'enfance particulier des événements qui
t'ont marqué dans une des pièces que
vous habitiez avant oui quand on n'était
pas sage drop 4e étage il y avait un le
placard au crocodile
et en a déjà vu des creux
incarnez le château le garder dans la
famille faire entrer les touristes dans
son histoire gagner suffisamment
d'argent pour l'entretenir et trouver
sans cesse de nouvelles sources de
revenus la marquise et le marquis de
vibrer sont toujours en action mais à
cet instant charles-antoine rigole
beaucoup moins
dépendants au coeur bien accroché
cheverny est connue pour ses belles
pelouses mais aujourd'hui elles sont
massacrés sans pitié car le marquis a
décidé de planter un hectare de vignes
le changement il est brutal et bien
attendez je savais que le passé un
tracteur avec une charrue à 6 oct ça
allait ça les pattes comme une tondeuse
telle qu'on aime on a l'habitude de les
entendre circulé il ya un petit
traumatisme au calme il veut produire du
sauvignon et du chardonnay la première
récolte aura lieu dans cinq ans et ce
sera le premier vin de cheverny une
nouvelle source de financement à
laquelle s'intéresse la presse locale
vous l'avez bien compris h et verte dans
une logique touristique on sait qu'on le
on pourra plus pousser les murs du
château pour accueillir davantage de
visiteurs on sait qu'on a un atout
énorme h et dernis et la place
ces vignes vont enrichir les 8 hectares
du domaine de cheverny dans lesquels
différents jardins ont déjà été dessiné
[Musique]
ce sont eux que la famille de marlon et
michael vont découvrir à travers un jeu
[Musique]
on garde tout trésor un coffret en plus
nos richesses doit de jouer maintenant
pour retrouver le trésor
chaque indice se trouve dans un des
jardins la toile et saufs
non
[Musique]
on a trouvé
grâce à toi c'est quoi
le 2e eu 13
[Musique]
les indices sont des rébus caché à
chaque fois dans une nouvelle partie du
domaine
ce parterre par exemple rassemble 300
variétés de fleurs différentes
[Musique]
ange est excité par cette chasse au
trésor les avant de poursuivre une pause
est nécessaire pour les enfants sous la
fraîcheur des brumisateurs
[Musique]
le jeu est une escapade dans le dédale
des jardins jardin des apprentis les
serres des arbres centenaires
[Musique]
allez
[Rires]
y le petit bond la balle tu es pont
blanc
les parents se prennent au jeu dans
l'immense domaine pour épargner ses
forces la famille emprunte une
voiturette pour s'enfoncer dans les bois
c'était quoi l'état les trésors du
chancelier après
et cachée dissimulée
[Musique]
la forêt de cheverny appartient aussi à
la famille de vibrer elle est plantée de
centaines de variétés d'arbres et
surtout de cèdre de plus de 40 mètres de
hauteur
et pour profiter de toutes les facettes
du domaine la balade se poursuit en
bateau électrique sur le causse ont un
petit affluent de la loire qui traverse
la forêt
passe devant
depuis ce matin la famille en prend
plein les yeux une guide leur donne même
un cours de botanique
les arbres au milieu textuellement
l'attend mais surtout qui aidé les
forces qui alors basta une forme de pied
d'éléphant et wii puis donc il a ce sont
des arbres à côté puisque leurs racines
se développe sous l'eau sur des mètres
de longueur qui ont été ramenés de
louisiane par l'ancêtre de l'actuel
propriétaire privé va semer botanique
donc là ils sont entre 150 et 200 en
multi mais on essaie vraiment à qui joue
du bach et c'est ça le char et l'abdomen
de cheverny
[Musique]
mais les petits explorateurs commence à
avoir hâte de retrouver la terre ferme
pour leur chasse au trésor il ne leur
manque plus qu'un indice pour ouvrir la
grille du beignet tapez le code secret
c'est quoi le cas devient roi 1 6 3 4
vas-y lenny 3
allez
[Musique]
est
ce que c'était
oui célébrer c'est un vrai trésor
il marque et bravo maintenant pour
demander ta part du trésor à l'accueil
de l'exposition
[Applaudissements]
les enfants sont heureux les parents
aussi ils ont aimé ces moments de
découverte en famille où les enfants ont
appris en s'amusant j'aimerais bien que
mes enfants voient l'histoire autrement
que j'ai pu la voir et en étant petit et
c'est justement en faisant des petits
voyages comme ça des petits séjours sur
la loire à vélo et pouvoir voir
l'histoire de france que j'aimerais leur
donner le goût
le goût de l'histoire parce que je pense
que c'est important qu'on sache d'où on
vient
donner le goût de l'histoire c'est bien
ce à quoi rêvent les deux vibrer
le dîner dans la cuisine est souvent le
seul moment de la journée où toute la
famille se retrouve
avec leur fils maximilien chaque soir le
sujet de conversation est le même
le maine d'angers vernis s'oblige à
paris de juin
maximilien à deux soeurs elle se destine
à d'autres carrières il sait qu'un jour
la lourde charge du château sera la
sienne
et pour surtout voir pour lancer journée
ce qui m'attend un maillon dans une
chaîne et s'il s'agit de ne pas être le
maillon faible de cette chaîne qu'on a
décidé
de mettre toutes les chances de notre
côté et d'habiter le château même voilà
pour que pour qu'ils soient imprégnés
par ce château est qu'il est vraiment
dans les tripes vous êtes toujours mis
ça dans la tête et inculquer que rien ne
devait être vendue en fait qu'est ce que
tu en penses
charles-antoine eric car il est
conscient de la pression qu'il fait
peser sur les épaules de son fils il a
eu la même c'est bien pour cette raison
qu'il a demandé ce soir aux vénitiens de
rester pour animer son château dans la
nuit à 22 heures le mystère des balles
de venise s'empare de cheverny
[Musique]
à 15 kilomètres de là le château de
chambord
il ne fut que peu de temps gardé par ses
héritiers c'est françois 1er qui en
avait demandé la construction à la
renaissance et c'est l'état français qui
en est aujourd'hui propriétaire
mais sa problématique reste la même que
pour les châteaux privés
toujours trouver plus d'argent pour
financer son entretien chaque année il
attire un million de visiteurs mais ce
n'est pas assez alors pour en attirer
encore plus l'édifice a été ravalée les
jardins redessiner l'an dernier des
travaux gigantesques de sept mois l'un
des plus grands chantiers d'europe
financé par un mystérieux mécène
américain amoureux du lieu un immense
projet de remeublement est également en
cours nathalie a la chance de venir
chaque jour dans le plus majestueux des
châteaux de la loire
elle vit juste à côté et elle est
consciente que les visiteurs sont le
nerf de la guerre alors pour eux tout
doit être parfait
voilà donc là je vais allumer le château
est donc s'allumer tâche paraît sage
nathalie travaille ici depuis 24 ans et
ce n'est pas un hasard
les châteaux en général pour moi déjà ça
une relation avec ma famille j'ai une
grand mère qui a travaillé dans un
château ma grand-mère était ce qu'on
appelle enfin ce qu'on appelait à
l'époque bonnet touffeur de mon
grand-père été garde-chasse sur la
propriété j'ai mon père a travaillé à
l'époque au château de cheverny qui est
à deux pas d'ici
ici ça fait comme une résidence
secondaire vu le temps qu'on y passe
et c'est valorisant de nettoyer pour le
plaisir des touristes un monument comme
celui ci pendant que nathalie astique
chaque recoin un tracteur aplani chaque
gravier de la cour d'honneur
il est 10 heures le château est prêt
pour accueillir le public qui veut
toujours en savoir plus sur l'histoire
des rois de france
après six heures de vélo la famille
arrive enfin aux abords de chambord
d'inspiration italienne la construction
de ce château a duré plus de 150 ans
156 mètres de façade quatre grosses
tours d'angle des tourelles qui s'élance
dans le ciel chambord et le plus
grandiose des châteaux de la loire la
visite coûte 13 euros par adulte
la famille a réservé un guide pour un
supplément de 5 euros par personne il
s'appelle aurélien et va les emmener
dans un voyage au coeur de l'histoire
alors on vient de rentrer le château
qu'est ce qu'on va en premier quand on
entend le château de chambord
2 on voit des grands escaliers alors les
enfants je vous propose qu'on fasse un
petit jeu vous allez monter de ce côté
et vous allez vous arrêter à la première
fenêtre et vos parents va monter de
l'autre côté on va voir ce qui va se
passer allez-y
cet escalier est unique à chambord on
l'appelle l'escalier à double révolution
en fait on y monte on y descend sans
jamais se croiser grâce à deux rampes
distinctes le centre est creux des
fenêtres ont été placées les unes en
face des autres toute la petite famille
peut se voir
alors de monter les étages les enfants
montrent de plus en plus vite ils
veulent arriver les premiers tout en
haut mais c'était sans compter sur la
rapidité de leur papa arriver avant le
la récompense c'est maintenant sur l'une
des terrasses emblématique du château
elle offre une vue imprenable sur les
jardins de 7 hectares qui viennent juste
d'être rénovée
à chambord tout est démesuré y compris
l'intérieur 426 pièces des suites
royales les visiteurs peuvent même
imaginer grâce une application de
réalité augmentée ce qu'était la vie
dans ce château au xvième siècle
[Musique]
la famille de marlon et michael va aussi
découvrir une des pièces les plus
énigmatiques de ce château si beau si
imposant est si puissant que le roi
soleil s'y fit aménager une chambre
on arrive dans la chambre de louis xiv
et regarder la petite balustrade en fait
ça servait à séparer l'endroit où
dormait le roi de l'espace où tous les
autres tous les invités pouvaient
rentrer juste à côté du lit vous voyez
la petite porte qui est caché on a une
pièce secrète ici qui était réservé au
roi eh ben on va y aller ensemble une
pièce secrète uniquement réservé au roi
mais pour y arriver il faut ressortir
sur la terrasse et ouvrir une porte dans
la clé est énorme
c'est ici dans cette pièce que le roi
pouvait vivre à l'abri des regards
ici c'était les parties privées
réservées aux rois de france et regardez
vous-même petite porte qui est caché si
votre avis qu'est ce qu'on va trouver
derrière
regardez ce jour
[Musique]
que vous avancez
regardez où on est
retour à la case départ directement dans
la chambre du roy la famille en prend
plein les yeux
on sent vraiment tout petit donc on
s'efface et on laisse le décor opéré
voilà nous permettent de s'émerveiller
devant lui tandis que la famille part
vers d'autres aventures à quelques
mètres de là sur une terrasse du château
voici eric il est chercheur et passionné
d'histoire il travaille à chambord
depuis 30 ans il est le seul à détenir
le code secret pour ouvrir les pièces du
château que le grand public ne peut pas
encore voir
et là nous quittons les espaces publics
pour aller vers des espaces plus privé
une démission d'éric et de comprendre à
quoi servez les combles du château
on n'a pas de commentaires de l'époque
qui nous raconterait comment les nobles
vivaient dans les combles et pourtant on
sait que ça a été parfois le cas la
seule chose qui en témoignent encore
aujourd'hui c'est la présence d' énormes
cheminées qui sont les mêmes cheminée
que dans les étages inférieurs donc
vraiment on est dans les espaces
d'habitation noble même dans les combles
sur une des terrasses une porte dérobée
mène à la plus haute tour de chambord
[Musique]
pour y monter comme partout ailleurs
dans le château démarche en tuffeau une
pierre très fragile
cette tour et la tour de la lanterne
avec une immense fleur de lys à son
sommet une tour très étroite dont eric
tentent chaque jour de comprendre à quoi
elle servait à l'époque de françois 1er
cette histoire il voudrait un jour la
raconter aux visiteurs
mais lorsqu'on constate aujourd'hui que
à deux personnes on est déjà un peu
serré lorsqu'on est au sommet on peut
penser que c'est un an voire très
réservé le roi dans leurs ouailles fait
seulement les honneurs à quelques-uns un
ambassadeur un souverain étranger en
visite dans les parages
j'étais par françois 1er aujourd'hui
rares sont ceux comme eric qui ont les
honneurs de pénétrer dans cette tour
toujours dans l'espoir de trouver des
financements et d'en raconter davantage
sur l'histoire des rois de france elle
sera peut être ouverte un jour au public
56 mètres plus bas marlène et mickaël
marche d'un pas décidé vers le spectacle
dans leurs enfants rêvent depuis des
mois le combat de chevaliers
à chambord joyau de la renaissance
bâtisse où françois 1er ils vont en voir
beaucoup ils sont là au pied du château
près des écuries il s'échauffe
celle qui commandent ces chevaliers
c'est christelle elle vient du quartier
du mirail à toulouse et sa passion pour
les chevaux l'amener loin de chez elle
[Musique]
c'est rare d'avoir un cheval avec autant
de freins donc c'est assez féerique quoi
je mets du démêlant pour l'écrin avant
de les peinière je fais des soins comme
pour nos enfin exactement la même chose
il aime bien en plus de douze chevaux
espagnols et 2,30 cascadeur elle gère
tous les costumes en soie velours et
taffetas reproduit comme à l'époque de
la cour du roi françois 1er pour le
spectacle
il est un peu petit costume pour toi
rien la note 'aaa' mabesoone celui qui
correspond à celui là en fait quelqu'un
adule comment ça se fait qu'il se
retrouve avec ça c'était plus costaud
talent costume le plus petit henry viii
tout et la cour d'henri viii qui lui
aurait vite du coup je mets le même
abattu mais le marron bien sûr
c'est à dire qu'il est pour une moitié
de toi ce costume tom particules
le spectacle démarre dans 10 minutes
tout est millimétré
chacun va mettre ses costumes en place à
peu près dans l'ordre du spectacle on a
quand même pas mal de changements il ya
sept tableaux on n'a pas le temps de
retourner à la posture et les
changements sont beaucoup trop rapide en
fait on est à peu près 4 sur chaque rôle
ça permet de permuter aussi s'il ya
quelqu'un qui se blesse parce qu'on fait
quand même des cascades donc ça peut
arriver ce matin moi je suis la reine
épervier belle de la cour
va lier tous se préparent à entrer en
scène
d'ailleurs les talibans
la famille de marlène arrive juste à
temps 500 personnes assistent aux
spectacles qui coûte 14 euros 50 par
adulte et 11 euros pour les enfants
c'est parti oui pour une heure de magie
en sept tableaux la vie du roi et
retracer
son mariage avec claude de france
ses nombreuses guerres d'italie
ses ennemis charles quint et henri 8 le
roi d'angleterre
mais aussi ce que les enfants attendent
avant tout et duel entre chevallier
c'est que ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
taclé cheval
est super
l'histoire à l'air de leur plaire à
chambord il se passe toujours quelque
chose pour faire vivre le château
pendant que la famille de marlène
assistent au spectacle de l'autre côté
du château l'une des quatre tours
d'angle s'est transformé en chantier
géant
ou encore un peu pour découvrir les
coulisses à 54 mètres de hauteur sur la
façade est une équipe de tailleur de
pierre s'affairent pour sauver une
partie du bâtiment
[Musique]
je tape pas trop à se faire à tomber
il faut arrêter l'hémorragie tout de
suite ces professionnels c'est pierre on
ne les trouve que dans la vallée de la
loire elles sont en tuffeau une pierre
blanche lumineuse mais très fragile à
l'heure l'opération est délicate
[Musique]
tél
bon
[Musique]
attention à une petite remarque est
juste en dessous tout doucement sont à
gauche là tu te mets en stand-by de
minutes
c'est assez rare quand même de
travailler que desharnais les ramenant
en position de danger ces hommes sont
des tailleurs de pierre mais pour
chambord ils doivent se transformer en
un ministre 12 pascal bouge pas mal la
manoeuvre se fait au centimètre près
décent et pour l'acheter tout le sport
ils vont l'apprendre les mains
ok c'est parfait il y a cinq cents
pierre comme celle ci a remplacé alors
chaque jour pendant trois mois les
tailleurs de pierre ont travaillé
d'arrache-pied
on va prendre les pierres une par une il
faut que ça soit frais pour les 500 ans
de chambord de toute façon nous n'avons
pas le choix l'erreur est et 0 lorsque
les travaux seront achevés
chambord aura retrouvé toute sa
splendeur une merveille d'architecturé
que certains ont la chance d'admirer en
prenant de la hauteur
[Musique]
je suis enfermé tu peux la mettre un peu
plus fort et ventilateur s'il te plaît
perdant depuis 12 ans jean homme
d'affaires est aussi pilote de
montgolfière
ils s'envolent chaque année en
participant au trophée françois 1er qui
permet de survoler la vallée des rois de
france vu du ciel
vérifiez la nacelle lancé les gaz pour
faire monter l'aérostat dans les airs
c'est tout un protocole oui j'en vois
cela pour manu la personne accès noir
j'ai demandé s'il perçoit pas de ballons
et une voix pour que je puisse monter
pour éviter de heurter un ballo c'est
dangereux et puis il m'a répondu que
personne donc je chauffe pour être le
ballon en chausses prêts à décoller en
douceur
[Musique]
le ballon et l'éloge de la lenteur
passé impressionnant ils montent à
seulement 3 mètres par seconde et se
déplace à 12 kilomètres/heure dans ce
paysage à couper le souffle 1
[Musique]
et là franchement on s'aperçoit que
c'est grandiose pour le penser quand tu
vois
petit j'ai toujours entendu parler de
chambord dans les livres d'histoire
après dans les livres architecture à
cette date demeure s'harmonisent bien au
ballon et les belles demeures voilà la
beauté
15 ballons viennent de s'envoler pour
admirer cette incroyable vallée
aujourd'hui il y as entre eux un petit
challenge avec une bonne bouteille à la
clé
le premier de la compétition amicale
c'est le ballon marchionne va se poser
c'est saint amans soult peut émettre au
sol une croix sur lequel nous pilotes et
en jeter si je lai petits sacs de sable
voilà le plus près possible de la cible
moi je fais attention sans plus j'aurais
dû rester beaucoup plus haut pour faire
de la gauche à la croix et labolina
croix jaune
et là qu'on freine avec les deux
brûleurs d'un coup
deux
ratés gens ne sera pas le grand
vainqueur aujourd'hui mais ça n'a pas
beaucoup d'importance car ces attentes
sont ailleurs volley aura des armes
comme en train de faire assez de toute
beauté
sous la nacelle la forêt de chambord
c'est la saison des naissances des
marcassins les bébés sangliers
dans le plus grand parc claude europe
des animaux vivent en totale liberté
dans le ciel les montgolfières de
laurent poursuivre leurs survols de la
vallée de la loire
sur terre près des écuries de chambord
la famille de marlène continue elle
aussi de se régaler
[Musique]
on pourrait se croire dans le livre mis
hier soir avant de partir ça reste
impressionnant ce tableau raconte la vie
dans les cuisines du château et les
tribulations des cuistots font beaucoup
rire les enfants
pendant ce temps côté coulisses
c'est la course la maintenance
changement de costume
de paysan se transforma chevalier
dernier tableau avec les rapaces dont
françois 1er se servait pour chasser ou
faire livrer les mauvaises nouvelles
[Applaudissements]
une heure plus tard le spectacle se
termine
après sept journées intenses la famille
et puiser à casser sa tirelire pour
aller dormir dans le nouvel hôtel de
luxe de chambord un bâtiment conçu comme
une gigantesque maison de campagne
contemporaine
à peine arrivé dans la chambre la
famille est émerveillé par les lieux
et par la vue ou c'est joli
à une terrasse tu vois
les enfants épuisés sont déjà prêts à
dormir avec les chevaliers de chambord
sûrement plein leurs rêves demain ils
reprendront leur vélo pour rentrer chez
eux
trois mois plus tard la famille a
tellement aimé venir à chambord qu'elle
a décidé de le découvrir à une autre
saison l'automne
elle a choisi de dormir dans ce gîte
situé dans le domaine de chambord pour
être au plus près de la nature
aller mais on va les voir ils ont laissé
les vélos et préférer la voiture là ce
gîte n'est qu'à quatre cents mètres du
château et pour y entrer on récupère la
clé sous le paillasson
tout simplement
je
sais les aliments qu'on va voir tout à
l'heure on va essayer de voir quels
sangliers biches lecerf
s'éduque on va essayer d'écouter le
bruit lorsque la nuit sera tombée la
famille ira voir les animaux et surtout
elles l'espèrent les serres car à
l'automne durant un mois c'est la saison
des amours et du brame du cerf mais pour
l'heure ils prennent possession des
lieux un gîte comme celui ci il y en a
que 3 h andorre ou ou la savate à la fin
de la cnil a tu vends savant deux petits
lits
qui va où aller c'est ben voila
voila
le coffre de la voiture est plein à
craquer michael et marlène le vide
rapidement ils ont peu de temps pour
s'installer dans leur nouvelle maison
avant leur grande aventure dans la forêt
ce jt il est super familial on s'y sent
bien le côté pratique c'est qu'il est
vraiment situé dans le parc de chambord
donc ça c'est super agréable pour les
enfants pas besoin de faire des
kilomètres et des kilomètres pour elle
dans la réserve et c'est dans la réserve
qu'ils iront justement ce soir pour
tenter de voir dessert toute la famille
en parle depuis une semaine j'espère
qu'on va les voir tout du moins de les
entendre c'est le but après de leur
expliquer et puis on verra bien cette
façon c'est la nature c'est elle qui
décide donc donc on verra mais je pense
que les garçons m a dit serais content
de les voir quand même donc on va
croiser les doigts
les enfants ont pris possession du parc
ce qui les change de la terrasse de leur
maison
non on va tous se détendent en attendant
que la nuit tombe
vous êtes prêt à l'éventualité de ne
rien voir non
[Rires]
il est 17h voici celui qui va les
emmener dans la forêt
guillaume un des guides du domaine de
chambord chanter les enfants
aller en forêt directement on a une
grande ferme qui a été aménagé exprès
pour l'observation libramont et puis on
va s'installer tranquillement voir si on
arrive à avoir des animaux
dans la réserve du domaine les animaux
vivent en liberté
[Musique]
bish marca sincères ils seront peut-être
tout cela ce soir
cette réserve l'une des plus grandes
d'europe est fermée au public que des
droits humains citant noir pour la
famille c'est un vrai privilège de
pouvoir y accéder et tout à coup
ce ne sont pas des cochons mais un
couple de sanglier avec ses marcassins
qui traversent la route
et quelques mètres plus loin coup de
chance
on regarde
[Musique]
le cers isole ce qui permet de mieux
l'observer
[Musique]
alors les enfants sur la tête dessert ce
ne sont pas des cordes ce sont des bois
la grosse différence entre les cornes et
les bois du cerf simplement que les
cornes ne tombe jamais de la tête de
l'animal par exemple une vache va avoir
des cornes sur la tête alors que les
serres les doit-on chaque année les
enfants ne sont pas au bout de leurs
surprises
guillaume les emmènent dans un bâtiment
au coeur de la forêt qui ressemble à un
grand corps de ferme un lieu dans lequel
tous devront respecter une règle d'or
fondé son nom la coupe a les portières
et on reste vraiment très silencieux
justement
les serres sont sensibles au bruit et
ils ont l'ouïe très fine en silence tous
descendre de la voiture pour se rendre
dans ce mirador un lieu d'observation
sur mesure
le cerf qui l'ont vu tout à l'heure et
sûrement juste à côté alors toute la
petite famille s'installe discrètement
derrière ce camouflage pour tenter de
l'apercevoir
à peine dix minutes plus tard
[Musique]
sur la gauche juste à côté du sujet
au loin un cerf rôde autour des biches
marlène michael et les enfants se
délecte du spectacle
quand soudain un bruit
le brame le cri du cerf pour attirer les
femelles pendant la saison des amours
tous sont subjugués
ce moment exceptionnel c'est entre mi
septembre et mi octobre qu'il se produit
[Musique]
les brusques ou cool
c'était vraiment bien
une heure plus tard la famille repart
heureuse et comblée par cette nature ne
serait pas
vous enlevez vos manteaux installé
prépare à manger de retour au gîte toute
la famille met la main à la pâte pour
préparer le repas la vision du cerf a
suscité bien des émotions
c'est même moi du haut de mes 30 ans je
n'avais jamais entendu le brame du cerf
et franchement c'est super affaire c'est
impressionnant et un tel qu'un beau un
beau regard vers l'horizon sur les
animaux sauvages qu'on voit pas dans les
eaux et ce soir le brame du cerf autour
d'une table conviviale on porte un toast
à la
mission attend ce soir la petite famille
passera sa dernière nuit à chambord
les châteaux de la loire offre
décidément des rencontres et d histoire
hors du commun
on en compte des centaines dans la
vallée des rois de france
ils n'ont donc pas fini de nous
enchanter
[Musique]